[Music]
choose and now it is time for you
to do the choosing
[Music]
from the very beginning the governor was
allowing covet positive patients to be
placed in the same nursing home as covid
negative patients
many in the legislature disagreed and
went to work to try and change the
policy
but the governor now has vetoed it
governor whitmer is still standing by
our policy of placing
coveted positive patients in nursing
homes with people who are covet negative
there hasn't been
one nursing home that has taken a
covid19 patient that they didn't think
that they were prepared to care for
across the state nursing homes are not
prepared with enough ppe
i'd like to hear what data was relied on
to pick
nursing homes to bring in covet patients
to infect those that weren't infected to
kill those loved ones
welcome to the debate stream we'll be
back uh after this really quickly with
the with the drinking
rule games the hashtags the promo code
but we wanted to start this off because
you know as it relates to debate um
uh i'm i'm a ham and egger really you
know i'm not i'm not not a pro
but this next gentleman is we wanted a
pregame with him he is a sitting senator
and a favorite of the show of course you
know his podcast is
the verdict or sorry verdict with tetris
the verdict is a paul newman film but he
does have a new book about the supreme
court one
vote away coming out october 6th senator
cruz
thank you for being here sir stephen
great to be with you uh
one one minor adjustment the book was
coming october 6th we actually released
it a
week early so today is its international
debut the
book one vote away all about the supreme
court
the bill of rights the constitution it
released today available amazon barnes
and noble
anywhere you buy books it's available
right now well i apologize for that i
thought when you said one minor
adjustment uh you were going to point
out that i needed to make an adjustment
so
thank you uh for uh correcting us so
it's available now at barnes noble where
those exist the only one around here is
a cafe
that happens to sell magazines
still counts so so stephen i gotta ask
something because the video just came
through
dear god man tell me you're wearing
pants i am yeah it's american flag
these are the butter bean shorts these
are regulation-sized boxing shorts
but uh after sitting down in front of a
current senator
i realize there's a reason that they
don't do the interview in the shorts
it's largely relegated to the ring
exclusively all right speaking of the
ring
we've got a barn burner tonight senator
cruz what do you expect
from the debates between donald trump
and joe biden do you think they still
might wheel out that old
like music class television with the vcr
with just a picture of biden's head on
it i'm not convinced he's showing up
so i i expect trump to
punch biden in the nose okay
probably figuratively and not literally
and i expect biden to
scream and run away okay
um now is this that seems literal not
figurative like i could see joe biden
actually doing that
well look he's been in the basement for
six months i don't think he's actually
seen human interaction um
look i i will say in in seriousness
um i'm worried that that conservatives
and the right have convinced ourselves
that that joe biden has
full-on dementia right uh
and and he's clearly slowed down a
little bit but but
if we were being honest joe said stupid
stuff when he was in his 20s
sure and we have defined
the bar down so low that no matter what
joe biden does if he falls on the ground
curls in the fetal position and cries
tomorrow the media will say biden one
right as opposed to reporting that
that's a repeat of his 88 campaign
which you guys can check the tape um no
i i think you're right and here's the
thing too
i'm not so much concerned about the low
expectations though i agree
i am just concerned as to as to whether
president
trump has bought into that and not
prepared because he could just joe biden
could be in the basement he could be
hitting you know
racks of beef for all we know and by the
way i've had relatives with dementia and
alzheimer's
and they can have moments of great
clarity where just as like a light
switch switches on
and then all of a sudden the circuit
breaks so um no i do think that's
important
except remember joe's running in the
democratic primary so he wouldn't
actually be hitting beef he'd be like
beating up on tofu somewhere
right yes exactly i think it'd be he'd
just be like smacking a spoon into miso
soup repeatedly
and that would be enough it'd be a it's
a soup spoon
um i think that's a good point let me
ask you this if you were
if you were president trump right now
you're going out tonight you're handling
joe biden what would you do how would
you handle it
focus on issues and substance okay we
win they lose on issues
free enterprise work socialism doesn't
rule of law the bill of rights and the
constitution they work
riots and anarchy and violence don't
um biden doesn't want this to be on the
issues
biden wants it to be a personality
contest biden wants it
do you like or dis or dislike donald j
trump and i think they think personality
contests they win i think that's why
biden's hiding in the basement is he
doesn't want to say anything
to disrupt whether some voters might be
upset
at the latest tweet or whatever what
have you
look this country is at a moment of
crisis 51 million americans have lost
their job
donald trump wants to open up the
economy joe biden wants to shut down the
economy that's a debate we need to have
right do you think that it maybe makes
it more difficult almost because
you know as opposed to for example let's
say the candidate where bernie sanders a
self-avowed socialist or like an aoc
that
joe biden you know who's been in
government for 48 years
kind of stands for nothing so it's
almost like trying to grab an amoeba
where
he can sort of maintain any position he
wants on the issues because he's
he's often been on both sides of them it
almost seems like it's it's tougher to
grab a hold of them
well look i think that's a challenge and
and
i don't know how much president trump is
prepared that's where preparing helps
when you can come back
with the substance and facts and record
i i think trump
will be quick on counter-punching uh but
i don't know that he will necessarily
have
all the facts at his fingertips and and
you're right
biden is going to try to backtrack and
claim
that that he hasn't alright here's a
classic example
on guns he's suddenly pretending he's
more reasonable on guns
rather than a a radical right now never
mind you that that biden said he would
put beto o'rourke in charge of gun
policy and when a reporter said
are you saying if joe biden were
president you're coming after our guns
it is response was one word bingo
right um i hope when joe tonight
pretends that's not the case
i hope the president's prepared to come
back with with biden's own record
right and the same can be said for
fracking the same can be said for a lot
for some of the wars
um let me ask you this having been there
sort of in the ring as it were with with
uh donald trump and he was kind of an
unknown entity right coming into the
primaries
what surprised you most at your debates
with with donald trump like was there
anything that you thought oh okay
maybe he has something some arrow in the
quiver here that uh i wasn't ready for
look trump is unpredictable um trump is
instinctual
um counter-punching is is his greatest
strength
um if you look at trump's debate with
hillary clinton
when he showed up at the debate with a
bunch of the
alleged victims of bill clinton's sexual
assaults
yeah and i'm not laughing at sexual
assaults i'm just laughing at the move
from the future of the united states it
was a
holy crap moment like like the press
nobody could speak
and and it was right after the billy
bush tape when trump was
like it was a rocky time
and his instinct is go on to go on
offense
yeah um i expect to see
see him go after biden
hunter biden corruption and it'll be
interesting to see if joe how he handles
that
yeah that was going to be my question is
how personal we think it's going to get
but i think that just sort of remains to
be seen and hopefully
if nothing else i think there's there's
an opening here for donald trump to do
the job that the media hasn't because
we've been watching cnn non-stop these
last couple weeks
and they haven't covered it since we've
been watching and i know for a fact that
abc hasn't at all
let's go find this because your book is
now out one vote away
about the supreme court that's going to
be one of the topics tonight
in the debate um what do you expect that
conversation to be
and how do you expect the media to
misrepresent it because this has been
one of those issues
that uh it's tough to attribute to
incompetence
what can be attributed to malice at this
point
now the media are hardcore democratic
partisans
i expect joe biden's talking point to be
the point talking point that democrats
are
consistently following which is to say
that if
judge barrett is confirmed as justice
barrett that the court will strike down
obamacare and it'll take away
protections for pre-existing conditions
um on the merits that's nonsense because
everyone every republican agrees we're
going to protect pre-existing conditions
right but more interestingly stephen
it reveals how defensive democrats are
on the court the fact that they want to
twist it into a health care issue
means joe biden doesn't want to discuss
free speech and the supreme court going
after our free speech rights he doesn't
want to discuss religious liberty he
doesn't want to discuss the second
amendment
the book i have that came out today one
vote away
each chapter talks about a different
constitutional
liberty one on free speech one on
religious liberty one on the second
amendment one on u.s sovereignty
one on elections and democracy it goes
into bush versus gore which i was part
of the legal team that represented
george w
bush in bush versus gore we could easily
see a reprise of that
this election cycle right and what the
book does is it tells the really
inside war stories of what's going on at
the court
what what what is the are the behind the
scenes of the major landmark
cases many of which i help litigate and
it's designed
you don't have to be a lawyer to enjoy
the book it's designed for anyone who
cares about
the bill of rights to explain all right
what's this all about
why does it matter why does it make a
difference in my life
it's interesting behind the scenes
stories about the justices about the
cases
and and what it illustrates is on issue
after issue after
issue the court is 5'4 and we are one
vote away we are one vote away
from the court taking away our free
speech rights our religious liberty
rights our second amendment rights
right and i hope that the president
makes some of that case tonight because
i think it is a
powerful and compelling case and the
democrats are scared about it which is
why they immediately go
to obamacare instead right no i i think
that obviously you can make that case
better than the president being a lawyer
you're a lawyer
yourself i will say this as a layman
when i try and research some of the
landmark supreme court cases
um often more definitive and something
that most americans never hear about are
the dissenting opinions right the ones
that lost
and to me the most concerning is heller
versus dc when you look at the
dissenting opinions
they were basically saying hold on it
wasn't okay ten round capacity magazines
it was a firearm case for people who
don't know go back and check it out
the dissenting opinion said that private
citizens have no actual constitutional
right to own firearms
whatsoever when it comes down to the
legal line how do we make the legal
argument it was either people have the
right to own guns
or they don't and that to me it was bone
chillingly scary and i think
americans would do well just to read up
on the landmark cases
well stephen you're exactly right heller
is one of the cases i talk about at
length because i represented texas and
30 other states in heller i helped
litigate heller i argued the companion
case
in the court of appeals and and you're
right the four to center so heller was
5'4
the four dissenters they weren't arguing
that some gun control laws are sometimes
okay
reasonable minds can disagree on that
question right
the dissenters instead argued and you
you put it exactly right
that the second amendment protects no
individual right
whatsoever that no american has any
right under the second amendment
which means the government could make it
illegal make it a crime
for you or i to own a firearm and the
four dissenters said
no constitutional problem knock yourself
out
and by the way hillary clinton and joe
biden both
pledged to appoint supreme court
nominees who would overturn heller and
and and in effect erase the second
amendment from the bill of rights
actually i have to fact check you they
pledged to appoint
more supreme court justices to overturn
eller versus dc oh we didn't get it yet
just add a co
what's a couple more let's make it a
baker's dozen then we can uh
then we can get beto in there somewhere
um i think
i think it's a very important point i'm
real i would love to read this book i
don't have it yet
uh this is one that i i desperately want
to read um and i know that i sound
uh desperate and and sad but that's just
who i am
um senator cruz well and stephen let me
jump in on something you and i have
talked before about how
ben shapiro and the daily wire guys when
they do their late night show
they use your cups as ashtrays which
which i for one have offended with
although i did partake
naturally but you know
i want this actually to be an
opportunity
for the battle of the right-wing
libertarian heavyweights and so i'm
doing
ben shapiro's show this week i'm doing
your show this week and you know what
we're gonna do
we're gonna keep a record of who more
moves more books okay whether louder
with crowder drives folks to go to
amazon or barnes and noble and buy the
book you can do it right now one vote
away
or whether shapiro does and and so we'll
see i i
i'm i'm thinking you're gonna take out
ben but but he's trying pretty hard too
well you know i don't really think it's
fair to call me and ben a battle of
heavyweights
i mean congratulations ben is that ben
is the toughest guy at a 14 year old
slumber party
so i don't want to look like a bully but
i appreciate you uh
a creative way to promote your book with
a little extra zing on the show
uh and i do think he'll probably sell
more in the amazon bookstore
physical crowd and will do pretty well
in the digital version but i love ben
and uh his tumblr is fine if you don't
mind asbestos my final question for you
uh senator cruz is you have to call it
who not the media will obviously say bye
and wins no matter what but if you have
to call objectively who do you think
comes out the victor tonight
trump because biden's out of touch the
media will love him but
biden is at the end of the day appealing
to the media elites who already agree
with him
and and if trump stays focused on
jobs on safety on security on what the
american people want
that's a winning message i agree with
you that's a good point he's really sort
of campaigning for the media and the
media is not as relevant legacy media as
they were in previous elections they're
becoming less and less relevant
uh hopefully we're becoming more
relevant because one vote away is a book
to be read we appreciate it senator cruz
be well thanks for taking the time
god bless
[Music]
stranger
by the way i heard you loud and loudly
and clearly
uh so just in that brick i rushed and
switched my shorts
we got some scissors see this but these
were actually sweatpants
that's much better we just got grabbed
some scissors took care of these shorts
should be lower
but then when i sit you're going to mess
it all up they become like gerald's
cycling shorts
they do and we have a lot of people
asking you to keep those on
yeah that's not why we're here i didn't
know that all of uh the hundred and
thirty thousand people watching wanted
to see inside of me
the stream by the way is crowded a base
stream please use that hashtag this is i
believe the most watched conservative
stream ever which i'm very surprised
uh it's considering how silly it is and
if you use the promo code
crowd or debate stream you will get 20
off oh for the next 24 hours
and of course uh do consider joining mud
club at louder with credit.com
mug club that's where we get the twenty
dollars off because our streams often
get
booted i said obviously it doesn't i'm
starting poorly you're very poorly how
are you jerry where's your fedora i'm
doing paint oh it's it's right here i
don't know
how do i put this my half asian lawyer
is here how are you hello i'm here to
moderate uh here to up here what do you
do
yeah you just you just that's your
outfit right you just uh you just
decided that you're gonna have a bow tie
yeah that's it that's it and then we
have audio weight uh quarter black
garage yeah what's going on
i'm ready it was a really rough era for
black guys
it was you know because you know they
all want to have big hair
but if you were a bald black guy and you
have to have mustache and a big hair and
a monk's cap that's pretty rough
yeah a lot of right you had to go for it
anyway so now is this this monitor or am
i
this bright and shiny no no it's just
okay all right all right so
uh we are going to be watching this
stream tonight by the way we want to
be watching with you uh via cnn we're
watching the fox news debate
via cnn just because you know they might
have like little fact checks and did you
know
oh yeah and of course nudie pictures of
brian stelter and don lemon
in the locker room with feraldo rivera
again so prediction oh that's right the
drinking game rules
the drinking game rules tonight are
bring them up
anytime you hear a leading or unfair
question of donald trump anytime he
drops a thug life moment
anytime uh china fake news is mentioned
with joe biden any time he gets a
softball question has a dementia moment
talks tough or from the shoulders he
says or if he says come on man
and you hear this ding you take a drink
and uh finish your drink you have to
doubt it if donald trump mentions hunter
biden
it's gonna happen yeah good lord do you
think it's gonna happen make sure
for sure i am very very concerned and as
a legal disclaimer
these rules are dangerous yes
very and by dangerous do you mean fun
well i definitely because
it's synonym day well we're not drinking
wine i mean i mean you can be but well
you are you know because you were
uh let's give a quick break down here we
just had ted cruz and i want to um
give you what let me let me go through
this first the best case scenario what
do you think best case scenario for
donald trump
best case scenario from joe biden what
do you expect to see all right so best
case for joe biden is that he does not i
feel like the bar is so low he just
doesn't
stumble through his part of the talk he
just is able to make points and he's
able to move through it without falling
down on his face and i really think
that's the so nobody turn on the
microwave exactly nobody turn on the
microwave the plate and his noggin can't
handle it that's right i think there's
going to be a joe biden catch man
it's one of nature's cruelest tricks
he's going to run out and catch him
and what do you think joe uh donald
trump so donald trump i think has to
he's got to be
he's got to be a little bit more subtle
than he normally is he can punch at joe
biden but he if he starts to beat up on
him and people start to feel sorry for
him
i think that'll be that is a challenge
when you're fighting someone with
special needs
and i say this as someone who's great
experience but fighting people with
which really
which really wasn't fair to me because
of some neurological component they're
insanely strong
it goes in order like a chimpanzee so
now you're the person that goes old man
strength
russian strength special needs strengths
yeah there are layers hey there are
levels to this game man
and special needs there's a reason that
they're not allowed in sanctions you've
got to be aware
so i was going to say i think gerald is
wrong and now i think
that the president should not lift up
his foot off the gas
when it comes to attacking biden because
this is one of those moments
where you've got to follow through with
all the rhetoric that we've been hearing
and everything that we've been seeing
from
the vice president over this entire last
couple of months is that he's going to
easily sail through that's his own
position and i just don't think it's the
case
there's been a lot of fun a lot of fun
poked at joe biden and some articles
written about how
we've lowered the bar so high so that
it's gonna be jumping you know he's
gonna lower it so high you lower it low
lower and low
lowered it so low he's actually he's
gonna be able to jump over it this is my
third language so get out of here
my point being you and gene simmons put
your fedora on
trump has gotta go hard he's gotta go
hard the whole time
yeah also because i think it will be
most entertaining for me which is the
point
so here's what i think is the best case
scenario for donald trump okay
i think early on joe biden has the balls
to do what he's been doing this whole
time on the campaign trail
where he calls donald trump's integrity
in a question you know this man isn't
fit for office this man
he denigrates the the the highest office
in the land
he should continue doing if he continues
doing that he opens up
uh the opportunity for donald trump to
go personal so what i'm hoping is he
does that on the outset
donald trump goes personal gets rid of
all of this on the outset
does the hunter biden burisma and then
after that hopefully wallace steps in
all right guys
you boss boys boys and allows them to
get to policy where donald trump can
also destroy biden right as far as
what i see best case scenario for biden
um
you know it's pretty tough he needs to
avoid any and all personal attacks i
would say he should avoid it because
that's donald trump's specialty and i
think he needs to lay out a positive
kind of
future for america which is tough to do
when you've suckled at the government t
for 48 years and have nothing to show
for it uh
but i think that's kind of his best path
to victory is to stay out of the mud
and he needs to stay off policy and if
it comes to policy joe biden does have a
little bit of a trump card for lack of a
better word
in that he is a moderate he should play
that up this is a debate now this is
something where it's a debate he needs
to play up being a moderate because
democrats
they have to run as moderates to win
elections republicans have to run
as conservative as they can to win
elections you see donald trump who was a
moderate really kind of uh
if you look at early on before he became
a republican candidate
then in the primaries and into the
general election he increasingly became
more conservative
you saw the opposite with hillary
clinton and you see joe biden saying
that he was of course going to ban
fracking until he's four fracking
um i don't know where he's going to
defend himself on on tpp
on nafta uh on the economy this is a
really really rough debate for
for buy now will say this too i think a
lot of people
are underestimating um just how much
they might be
underestimating donald trump so people
are saying hey they're setting really
low expectations for biden yeah i think
that's true
buying just needs to not crap himself
right five needs to make it through
without the
without the crinkle and his depends
going away because you know it's moist
maybe a feet your pants filled out but
donald trump the same thing with donald
trump people are expecting him to be
such a bombastic jackass
because they've sort of developed their
impression of donald trump through
how they see him conveyed in the media
this is one of those rare instances keep
in mind when donald trump started doing
those um
those press briefings when kovid started
his approval rating went up
the moment he started speaking directly
to the american people this
unlike the town halls should be one of
those instances where a lot of people
who are undecided or people who aren't
just democrats or just republicans
will hear from donald trump himself and
so he just needs to be a little more
likable just
likeable enough to give them a reason to
pull the lever for the guy who doesn't
have dementia and crap his pants every
time
you try and make a hot pocket it should
be an easy choice and and i
definitely think that's a really good
point is that this has got to be the
moment where joe biden
really abandons blm and and antifa and
the other far left
if he really wants to win this election
because so many folks are going no i'm
i'm not a fan of so many real americans
who may be undecided in this election
are saying i'm not in favor of burning
down cities burning down businesses and
creating this kind of
is that lindsay oh never mind that's the
other trump though
yeah now that's donald trump's daughter
watch your mouth no i think you need to
abandon them
like biden's kids who never call call
your father
and it can be really short because he
won't remember you just go you call them
in 30 seconds and you go well dad this
has been a nice 45 minutes but
i've got to get going oh i also forgot
we have the costume contest yeah
we have a costume contest for everyone
out there watching right now
we will be uh i wouldn't say reading but
we'll be showing the costume contest
winner and you get a block of gerald's
hair also of course do not forget i
don't know
michigan friday october 2nd noon
in lansing the state capitol building uh
i'll be right
hey governor whitmer we're going to be
in your backyard going through all your
private stuff you better come out and
pound me
also chat we're going to be doing some
chat after this we go to the exclusive
mug club show
where we will be doing chat with people
live who are mug club because we don't
do super chat on youtube because they
don't pay nothing
um so a real quick question yeah how
does he get the base fired up because
nobody is excited about voting for joe
biden
you guys are saying that he has to go
more moderate that doesn't fire that's
what i think people have it wrong
because they go oh joe biden you know
they're just really voting for him
because he's not trump right that's what
people
but the truth is there's no enthusiasm
for biden if people hated trump that
much
that enthusiasm would translate to the
yang of the ying right you know
it would sort of be a mirror image where
you would think they'd be enthusiastic
for anyone not named trump but that's
not what we're seeing right there's very
little enthusiasm there's no enthusiasm
for bible that's what i'm saying how
does he get
there to be enthusiasm so you said he
would have to go more to the center
right he would have to be a moderate and
have to play that doesn't fire anybody
he can't get he can't get enthusiasm
that's the thing that that ship has
sailed okay yeah that [ __ ] right has
sailed with his iq with his function
that ship has sailed likely with all of
his pants the thing all of his previous
underpants
pre-adult diapers which by the way i
don't know if depends is the only name
brand it's just like it's kind of like
kleenex
tissue paper q-tip i mean joe biden
soils himself
yeah so i don't want it to be lost on
you we're like it depends there
there's some other person who wants to
sponsor the show there are many
hard-working adult
diaper manufacturers of the united
states by the way thank you that's
probably a part of the united states
mexico canada agreement okay that's
donald trump okay that's his wheelhouse
so you should thank him
but don't get mad at me you need a
better branding plate depends has been
kicking your sorry
undiapered ass for a long enough time
let's go now i believe the debate
is starting with chris wallace i wonder
what effect that will happen oh no
one more thing too there were demands
made for tonight's debate obviously the
drug test or request
i think this is so telling donald trump
wanted them both to submit themselves to
drug tests he consented biden declined
he wanted them to do ear checks before
the debate for electronic devices yes
he consented donald trump said i'll do
it myself in biden declined uh and then
biden wanted two breaks
yeah yeah for 90 minutes one every 30
minutes
and a snack he needs a sound yeah he
wanted a napkin
some warm milk with honey which i didn't
even know was still a thing but
apparently he finds it soothing
so again when you're talking about the
energy level there are legitimate
criticisms against donald trump yeah
there are legitimate criticisms of of
joe biden
but this idea that joe biden has the
energy or that donald trump doesn't
they're both old
it's not even common not even the same
it's not even comfortable donald trump
has more energy than most 20 year olds
and the fact that he was willing to
i think it's brilliant he's getting in
his head with the drug test with the
device in the ear i'm still not
convinced i am not convinced that they
aren't going to bring out
just like one of those minority report
spiders with a monitor
of vitamin space like mojo that's what i
think they might be doing here i i
won't believe it until i see it they're
gonna run an eight out there and be like
oh he he fell down and broke his hip we
can't we can't do it he's offended
positive for kova just before the show
and so he doesn't want to get the
president sick out of being a response
respect
they're gonna send out the same person
who hillary trotted out for a concession
speech
i mean look i called it last time when
we were into the last stream i said
there's no
question in my mind that trump is gonna
pull it down all and pull some evidence
out of his pocket
but it's gonna be something that props
drives joe biden over the edge by the
way might be a pg-13 rating tonight
because people could get mad in their
drinking games and uh we were talking
about the new york trump tax returns
and we talked about the tax code and of
course people who say he hasn't paid
taxes remember there was a scandal from
rachel maddow that he only paid 38
million oh
they're starting look there he is the
years of covet has not been kind to him
he didn't get it does he know he's on
camera i think he's giving him a message
joe biden is done do we have any sound
guys there's nothing
there's nothing we have no sound is that
coming from c that's from the stream
i think they're paul i just hear them oh
yeah you can hear them breathe or
anything on there
well now i don't hear them this is them
this isn't us save them
wow more viewers than cnn and a better
audio guy
i'm chris wallace
this debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
the commission has designed the format
six roughly
15 minute segments with two-minute
answers from each candidate to the first
question
then open discussion for the rest of
each segment
both campaigns
i decided the topics and the questions
in each topic
i can assure you none of the questions
has been shared with the commission
or that story that's circulated today
which i don't think was true
but it was funny to entertain it we know
what happened last time with donna
brazile
exactly which is serving as the health
security advisor to the commission for
all four debates
as a precaution both campaigns have
agreed
so we and more importantly you can focus
on what the candidates have to say
no noise except right now as we welcome
the republican nominee
president trump and the democratic
nominee
vice president biden
he said
they're already putting joe at a
disadvantage look at joe biden he's
doing his fists his fisticuffs
he's showing you his veiny liver spotted
knuckles
if he were to try and throw a punch at
your head you would just need to duck
your skull and his knuckles would have
he came out
he came out the right hand he came out
that's good check his ears first subject
is the supreme court president trump you
nominated amy
coney barrett over the weekend to
succeed the late
ruth bader ginsburg on the court you say
the constitution is clear
about your obligation and the senate's
to consider
is the concept i nominated the court
vice president biden you say that this
is an effort by the president and
republicans
to jam through an appointment and what
you call
an abuse of power my first question to
both of you
where do you think a justice barrett
would take the court president trump in
this first segment you go first
two minutes thank you very much chris i
will tell you very simply we won the
election
election president election year 29
times the
house and somebody we have nine out of
ten times nominated exactly
republican and senator
in fact some of her biggest endorsers
are very liberal people from notre dame
and other places so i think she's going
to be fantastic we have plenty of time
even if we did it after the election
itself i have a lot of time after the
election as you know
so i think that uh she will be
outstanding she's going to be
uh he does know as good as anybody that
has served on that court
i really feel right we have a professor
at notre dame highly respected by all
said she's the single greatest
student he's ever had he's been a
professor for a long time at a great
school
and uh we just uh we won the election
and therefore we have the right
to choose
and by the way the democrats they
wouldn't even think about not doing it
if they had the only difference is
they'd try and do it faster
there's no way they would give it up
they had merit garland
but the problem is
so we won the election and we have the
right to do it chris
president trump thank you yes um same
question to you vice president biden you
have two minutes
well first of all um thank you for doing
this and
looking forward to this mr president i
uh
he sounds sick he doesn't have a right
to have a say
who the supreme court nominee is and
that say occurs
when they vote for a united states
senators and when they vote for
the president united states they did
they're not going to get that chance now
because we're in the middle of an
election for the president and they
voted the same party
added seats in the last three midterms
for republicans four years that's the
whole point that's the term i thought it
was four years should happen
yeah i didn't think we should wait
almost four years you should wait and
see what the outcome is
because it can only counter that right
hand the american people get through the
other one
is by who they elect as president and
who they elect as vice president
now what's at stake here is the
president's made it clear
he wants to get rid of the affordable
care act he's been running on that yeah
he ran on that and he hasn't been
governing on that
he's in the supreme court right now
trying to get rid of uh
the the affordable care act is that this
woman of the law
revered by both sides right won't just
follow the insurance
health insurance number or we wanted the
affordable care act
insurance premiums rose 105 in 39 states
deductibles uh higher than 20 percent in
some brackets
no that doesn't sound like this far
outpaces the average cost so
you can like the affordable care act in
theory but
it's well past time to deconstruct it it
hasn't worked it's hurt everybody
all income brackets we know it
verifiably economists will tell you that
now
that's not in dispute it's only an
ideological win that he wants to
preserve
more money because she has a
pre-existing condition of pregnancy
we're able to they were able to charge a
woman more for the same exact procedure
amanda
gets and that ended with
affordable care act and there's a
hundred million you know what i do love
pre-existing conditions nothing about
this is focus on
qualifications qualifications or the
actual legality of the procedure
it's all about some hypothetical
decision that might be made down the
road but he's not even addressing the
law itself
he's just saying fear fear fear you
might not get everything you want from
the government
you might not get to keep your shitty
more expensive healthcare by 105 percent
that i sat by and nodded while the first
black president you know
and i you know i said put my name on
there
okay justice ginsburg said very
powerfully very strongly
at some point ten years ago or so
she said a president and the senate is
elected for a period of time but a
president is elected for four years
we're not elected for three years i'm
not elected for three years
so we have the senate we have a
president during
a period of time during that period of
time we have
an opening i'm not elected for three
years i'm elected for four years
and 100 million people jill the hundred
million totally wrong i don't know where
you got that number
the bigger problem that you have is that
you're going to
extinguish 180 million people with their
private health care that they're very
simply not true well you said you're
going to socialism
we're now into open discussion open
discussion discussion yes i agree
god had vice president number one he he
knows that uh what i proposed
what i proposed is that we expand
obamacare
oh and we increase it we do not wipe
anything
okay so we can watch premiums go up 120
of my colleagues trying to win the
nomination sorry 220 percent
that's doubling i only added five
percent you know what he said about
pre-existing conditions that's the
linchpin of their argument
and trump has already said i have a plan
for that we're going to make sure we
cover that
that is simple and it'll be cheaper and
better does it include rape kits like uh
tara reid they're buying
right now and they're gonna dominate you
joe you know that
i am the guy right now the platform of
the democratic
party is what i in fact approved of
what i approved of oh now here's the
deal the democratic party
is going to wipe out bernie sanders and
kamala harris
what does it mean for them going forward
if you strike down
the affordable care act joe you've had
308
000 military people dying because you
couldn't provide them proper health care
in the military so don't tell me
about trafficking
when they do the health care debate the
va should
[Music]
which was heavily infected you didn't
want me to ban all right
gentlemen you're right you would have
been much later
mr prime minister later mr president
about 2 million
because i have the timeline i went
through last time as to what donald
trump did you know january 31st
they announced the chinese travel
restrictions february 24th pelosi was
saying you should flock to chinatown
february 29th they had a level 4 travel
advisory to areas of italy south korea
europe
and joe biden was nowhere to be seen
march 15th it's on the ballot in the
court then he was gone
he appeared in march march 15th and then
and then his
primary uh advisor simone sanders went
on cnn and said that the cdc said it was
safe for 50 or more people to gather
he was gone yeah he had nothing to say
for months
right into the basement uh on health
care and
then we'll come back to roe v wade all
right mr president the supreme court
will hear
a case a week after the election in
which the trump administration along
with 18
state attorneys general are seeking to
overturn
that's right obamacare to end obamacare
you have spent the last year because
they want to give
good help if i may ask my questions sir
good health care
over uh the last four years you've
outpaced your premiums by 9 000
but you have never in these four years
what's my deductible it doesn't matter
as long as it's less than 200 grand per
quarter
obamacare of course i have well
it takes a small pharmacy to trot out on
this stage jfk has got
nothing on me that is absolutely a big
thing that was the worst part of
obamacare
chris yeah that's the worst part of it
let me ask my question i'll ask joe
individual mandate was the most
unpopular we can't really hear it
oh they froze they froze already
cnn stream froze already i think he's
gotta be careful right i think he has to
be careful donald trump has to be
careful he needs to not
interrupt the uh the moderator right now
again this is what people are waiting
for him to do he should just wait for
his spot
pick his spot once he gets a question
and he can answer because joe biden is
not doing very well
he sounds really sick is it just me he's
getting arrested
it sounds very gravelly it's lower it's
slower and
it seems as though he's trying to speak
in a way that prevents it from cracking
right like he's got some you know
something going on an upper respiratory
type deal
right but but i'm right with you there i
i think that the president there's
flirting with with a little bit of you
know he's got all this information that
he wants to present
but it's not just that you have the
information it's whether or not you can
actually present it well
and going after the moderators nobody's
done that
and make sure that we're checking chat
to make sure the audio is loud enough
and people absolutely
do watch along with us because cnn has a
pretty faulty digital stream
and uh of course yeah i know we're going
to be speaking a little bit we want you
to hear the context but
hopefully provide some fact checking had
to switch to abc's we're doing
prescription drug prices
we're going to allow our governors now
to go to other countries to buy
drugs because they pay just a tiny
fraction
discussion
you'll be happy i'm about to pick up on
one of your points
to ask the vice president which is he
points out joe biden was like
little shark out notification to
obamacare
that he makes make is that that is going
to end
private insurance it is well and when he
[ __ ]
he says it will end private insurance
and create a government takeover of
healthcare it does not it's only for
those people who are so
poor they qualify for medicaid they can
get that free
in most states except governors who want
to deny people or poor
medicaid well actually one in three
doctors
one in three doctors now don't want to
take medicare medicaid the public
option the vast majority of the american
people would still
not be in that option number one so you
agree
with bernie sanders far left on the
manifesto we call it what matters is you
socialize medicine
look hey are you still not going to
listen to him the fact of the matter is
i beat bernie sanders not very much
i'm here standing first i don't think
he's going to play well for trump
very lucky tonight as well and tonight
i'm going to make sure
because here's the deal here's the deal
the fact is that everything he's saying
so far
is simply a lie i'm not here to call out
his lies everybody knows he's a liar but
you i just want to make
sure he has the eyes of a makeup show
make sure you did last in your class
tonight first and foremost
i want to make sure president can you
let him finish sir no he doesn't know
how to do that
he has
this is an opportunity that donald trump
has to
reach viewers who didn't tune into the
town hall this isn't going to play well
he needs to get by enough room to answer
so that he can rebut it skull's given
up socialized medicine mr president tell
you what
he is not for any help for people
needing health care because his because
he
in fact already has cost 10 million
people their health care
that they had from their employers
because of his recession
number one number two
he had unemployment at 3.5 before
coronavirus in
your blue state lockdowns dummy barack
obama had unemployment over 9
for over a year into the front front end
of his presidency
labor force participation right actually
increased by the most
the most significant amount ever in any
single week
in 2019 labor force participation was an
all-time low with barack obama where
they just thought well you know it's
because boomers are getting out of the
workforce
we're never going to have the labor
force participation rate come back and
then we realize oh no way
shitty president whoops we guarantee
pre-existing conditions but took away
the individual mandate
listen this is the way it is and that
destroyed
that they shouldn't even actually i love
it i want jonathan i don't have a choice
do i let my people run it really well or
badly if i run it badly they'll probably
blame him but they'll blame me but more
importantly i want to help people
okay i said you're going to run it so
well that's amazing and i just had a
meeting with them they said the problem
is no matter how well
you run obamacare it's a disaster it's
too expensive
premiums are too high that it doesn't
work we do want to get
i have to give you roughly equal time
please let the vice president talk good
he has no plan for health care yes we do
please he sends out wishful thinking
he has executive orders that have no
power he hasn't lowered drug costs for
anybody he's been promising a health
care plan
since he got elected he has none like
almost everything else he talks about
he does not have a plan well you know
for a man who doesn't have a plan
to get the unemployment rate to less
than half they get the average wage
growth to more than
double or triple depending on the
numbers you use uh compared to barack
obama to get the black unemployment rate
to record low if you get the labor force
participation rate
uh going gangbusters to record not
recognized within a singular period
for a guy without a plan some i guess in
that case
sign me up for a guy without a plan as
opposed to a shitty one it seems to be
working
but in fact it wasn't brought up by the
president it was brought up by some of
your democratic colleagues
in i'm saying the congress so my
question to you is you have refused in
the past to talk about it
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not
you will support either ending the
filibuster
or packing the court whatever position i
take in that that'll become the issue
the issue is the american people should
speak
you should go out no you should speak
if i actually provide a clear answer to
your question if i actually take a
position like a guy who's sacked off and
dropped a pair
you know it might be a problem for me
i'm trying to shift in really unnoticed
kind of like you know the fire drill
where people don't know that i haven't
gone out single file i'm no longer with
my homeroom class
i just want to sort of wedge myself in
there go unnoticed if i say
whether i support court packing or not
well you know kamala harris is just
going to be really upset and i
i don't need any more pegging keep
yapping man the people understand yeah
47 years you've done nothing they
understand all right
the second subject is 19. that is
true seriously 47 i
million cases of coronavirus in the
united states and more than two
hundred dollars damn it have died
after we produce a vaccine experts say
that it could be
months or even years before we come back
to anything
approaching normal that's not true my
question
for welfare is based on what you have
said yeah the unemployment rate that's
right round two
thank you your camera's that way
starting in 2021
people keep spinning around we have the
worst camera man
you look lovely trying to follow your
health points the camerawork is shoddy
this is so fast it's not your fault the
question goes to you first sir
two minutes uninterrupted good luck good
luck
two hundred thousand dollars
uninterrupted as you said over seven
million in effect in the united states
we in fact have five percent or four
percent of the world's population
20 of the deaths 40 000 people
a day a huge portrait can be attributed
directly to new york
new jersey and by the way michigan
michigan has the worst
coveted nursing home policy and there's
some information that you may not have
which we'll go over
at the state capitol in lansing on
october 2nd noon
that's going to be a big one so michigan
is possibly one of the worst states but
if you eliminate the nursing home
policies
uh really you eliminate a huge portion a
majority of the deaths
so much better he knew it was a deadly
disease
what did he do ban travel which you
called it he knew it he demanded it
tell us or give people a warning of it
because he didn't want to pay
all right i got to go through this
timeline again with the covid okay let
me make sure i get this right just so i
don't forget it because i don't want to
be fact-checked
you guys can keep it up there until i
get through the timeline to be able to
go to wuhan
and determine for themselves how
dangerous this was
he did not even ask she to do that he
told us what a great job
she was doing he said we owe him a debt
of gratitude
for being so transparent with us and
what did he do then
as late as march de blasio
and nancy pelosi were telling people to
go eat dumplings in chinatown and go to
movie theaters
march 2nd july long after he banned
travel from china yeah and we knew a lot
more on march 2nd than we did
and declared it a national emergency in
order to be able to go out
and get people the help they need to
keep their businesses open
open schools that cost a lot of money
you should get out of
i don't have anything from buy
sandwiches you did nothing and he was
completely
watching other than criticize donald
trump you did nothing
that's not what a leader does by the way
you don't just sit on the sidelines just
throw hot shots at a guy you go here's
what we should have been doing
none of them have if we would have
listened to you the country would have
been left wide open
millions of people would have died not
two hundred thousand and one person is
too much it's china's fault it should
have never happened
they stopped it from going trying to
drink and by the way when you talk about
numbers you don't know how many people
died in china
you don't know how many people died in
russia you don't know how many people
died
exactly i'm going to be a corona virus
but if you look at what we've done
i closed it and you said he's xenophobic
he's a racist
and he's xenophobic because you didn't
think i should have closed our country
wait a minute it says two minutes you
didn't think we should have closed our
country because you thought it was too
it was terrible you wouldn't have closed
it for another two months
by my doing it early in fact dr fauci
said president trump
saved thousands of lives many of you a
democrat governor said
president trump did a phenomenal job we
worked with
him back then cuomo said it would be
hard to imagine a president
doing in fact
people that would not be necessarily on
my side
president trump did a phenomenal job we
did
we got the gowns we got the masks we
made the ventilators you wouldn't have
made ventilators and now we're weeks
away from a vaccine
we're doing therapeutics also keep in
mind that the federal stockpile that was
depleted by the obama administration
who was in this vice obama they walked
in and the only thing left was was a
crumb too small for a mouse
because that's the way it is
unfortunately but let me just tell you
something i don't care i've gotten used
to it
but i'll tell you joe you could never
have done the job i feel like joe
14 thousand people died not two hundred
thousand there was no
economic recession you made up there
there was no way
you made a point let him answer and
there was no one there's no we didn't
shut down the economy
this is his economy what that was your
it is the blue states that have been
shut down by the way unemployment in new
york
is up as high as 40 percent we have that
as an overlay you know we will have all
this available on the website afterwards
but all of this can be confirmed
the the states that have had the most
severe lockdowns have had the worst
virus spread okay there is no real core
there's no correlation between lockdowns
working and i don't want to claim the
opposite if you don't have a lockdown it
works but certainly if you look at texas
and florida
it's a third that of states like new
york it's less than half
that of states like michigan and then if
you look at the unemployment it's double
triple quadruple in the blue states they
have higher deaths
they have higher mortality and they have
higher unemployment when when he says
we didn't shut down the economy you
tried to shut it down now i get it with
swine flu because swine flu wasn't
nearly as deadly but we can't let that
go unchecked okay we've got to go back
to this
johnson five years by the way gentlemen
and gentlemen let me let me move on
into reg i think that was questions
about the future because you both
touched on one of the
two of the questions i'm gonna ask a few
years now i'm pretty sure swine flu was
somewhere around fourteen thousand was
it you have yeah
but it was also tough because they but
they also weren't measuring everyone who
had the flu as a suspicion it's not a
direct comparison which is what's
happening
head of the centers for disease control
dr redfield said it would be
summer before the the vaccine would
become generally available enough reg
finding that you can let us know
i think that sounds confused and
mistaken those are your two words
but dr slowly the head of your operation
worf speed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives it is a very political
thing i've spoken to foreign before the
election
johnson and johnson was a muslim they
can go faster than that by a lot
yeah a couple things there were a couple
people who said they wouldn't trust the
vaccine
solely because it would happen before
the election it might have been kamala
harris newsome or joe biden
except the drug companies came out and
said we will likely have something in
october
he said it couldn't be there but he
could also be much well you're supposed
to trust big
pharma when they say that we should shut
down the economy but not trust them when
it actually uh
happens in their wheelhouse developing
drugs the answer
before when it comes to the economy
trust the pharmacist when it comes to
pharmacology
delivered right away we have the
military all set up logistically
they're all set up we have our military
that delivers soldiers
and they can do two hundred thousand a
day they're going to be disagreeing with
the same man
it's all set up by easter this would be
gone away
by the warm weather it'd be gone
miraculous like a miracle reg said it
was kamala harris it was kamala
that would take care of it this is the
same sarcastic that was you know that
i would have said sarcasm so here's the
deal this man is talking about a vaccine
every serious every serious company is
talking about
maybe having a vaccine done by the end
of the year but the distribution of that
factor no that's not true
that is not true there are several
companies that have talked about having
a vaccine done by october or at least an
answer by october there are several that
have said third phase trout will be done
by october which means they can give an
answer to the american public right
these people don't want an answer before
october right yeah right right right if
a new
drug comes up yeah if a new drug comes
on the market again right
and it's approved it's made it through
phase three trials where there's
basically just some paperwork to be done
and red tape to cut through which by the
way is what operation warp speed
cuts they make that announcement hey we
have a new uh
autoimmune uh drug that works hey we
have a new cancer treatment that
they always keep people updated of that
uh of the clinical trial and the biggest
the biggest criticism is
well it's not going to be distributed
well of course that's just that's just
the way that it works
we're talking about is there a path to
an exit out of the
era and there is that's when you get the
vaccine solved and then you still have
to go through the hurdles
of distribution they said they wouldn't
take the vaccine if it came out and now
they're saying
we don't even want an answer before then
yeah right
why don't you want the information
before election oh i think i know why
mr mr nine percent unemployment work for
him
their job doesn't depend on him
they're the people by the way to the
scientists that are in charge by the way
they will have the vaccine very
seriously
do you believe for a moment yes what
he's
telling you in light of all the lies
he's told you about
the whole issue relating to covet he
still hasn't even acknowledged
that he knew this was happening
two million are gonna die okay two
million aren't going to die
what do you mean which lies joe a lot
smarter there are lies and there
is changing information and the experts
have been wrong
about everything everything as it
relates to covenant
the only person more wrong than the
scientific experts who the left loves to
tout
if you want to save the most vulnerable
among us old people and the sick
you would do the exact opposite of what
states like michigan
and new york are doing because guess
what if we keep this never-ending
lockdown in court
it's no safer no for 80 year olds three
four five months from now
i was saying this and i almost got
banned on youtube we got told
you're you're getting into the dangerous
air traffic why don't we just quarantine
sick
and old people and my own doctor dr choi
korean i know you're not a huge fan you
know you guys have your little
south koreans i love koreans oh that's a
novel idea
no it's a sensible one now the virus is
handled going forward by
whichever of you ends up becoming the
next president i want to quickly go
through several
of those reopenings vice president biden
you have been
much more reluctant than president trump
about reopening
the economy and schools why sir because
he doesn't have a plan if i were running
i know how
what the plan is what is that to provide
these businesses
because he's under the plan and then he
said because if i were running nobody
just said as well as you're running it
i had a plan you have to provide them to
nazi pelosi
well he's just shush for a minute tell
it
it's humorous by the way nancy pelosi
and schumer
they have a plan he doesn't even know
he's eating dim sum
in chinatown come on down he
sits on his golf course sorry that was
late february it was
de blasio in march you said go to
theaters but you know what i mean
tomato grandpa's dead shut down this
country
oh and i want to keep it open and we did
it
wait a minute let me shut you down for a
second joe just
rick he wants to shut down the country
we just went through it we had to
because we didn't know anything about
the disease now we found
that elderly people with heart problems
and
diabetes and different problems are very
very vulnerable we learned a lot
young children are in new york and worst
of all in michigan they send
young sick patients but shut it down
right more people
will be hurt by continuing if you look
at pennsylvania if you look at certain
states that have been shut down they
have democrat governors all
one of the reasons why they shut down
because they want to keep it cheap
because unlike michigan they were
actually accurate in their numbers
68 of all their deaths were seniors
nursing homes related
68 in canada it was 80 percent michigan
they said well it's 34 guess what lie
october 2nd lansing state capital
it's going to be absolutely i hope you
have your barn burning shoes
you have to understand if you look i
mean i have a mask right here i put
a mask tonight as an example everybody's
had a test
bring up that water melon and judge
malice i wear masks when needed
when needed i wear a mask okay let me
ask i don't have i don't wear mess like
him every time you see him he's got a
mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
look the way to open businesses is give
them the wherewithal to be able to open
how we provided money the current i was
asking
if you think that supports a business
for example let's say a business like
this with
15 employees you are out of your tree
sir
no no serious person said the opposite
no
bill gates doctor huge supporter of the
democratic party by the way said we
should lock
everything down until there's a vaccine
you won't take the vaccine
if it comes out before the election one
last
subject because masturbate your
different approaches has even affected
the way that you have campaigned is that
what's going on president trump you're
holding
large rallies with crowds packed
together
in any case why are you holding the big
rallies why
you not you goes first sir because
people
want to hear what i have to say
25 35 000 people show up at airports
we use airports we have a lot of people
well so far we have had no problem
whatsoever it's outside that's a big
difference according to the
experts but we do them outside we have
tremendous
crowds
and joe does the circles and has three
people someplace
and by the way i'm gonna need another
beer here soon bring back up the
drinking game
for people who don't remember here
that's what he said i can't i'm gonna be
okay he's not worried about you he's not
worried about the people out there
october 2nd she said well yeah his
rallies are a violation by executive
order
who the hell are you all right right you
get to stop people from exercising their
first amendment right outside
because of a cough namely the president
yeah right yeah
it's not like it's an important thing
going to hear your leaders speak to you
in person from the shutdown
much faster in the second quarter the
unemployment rate fell to 8.4
last month the federal reserve says the
hit
to to growth which is going to be there
is not going to be nearly as big as they
had
expected president trump you say we are
in a v-shaped
recovery issue vice president biden you
say it's more of a case
why you couldn't even spell difference
does that mean
the american people in terms of the
economy president trump in this
segment you go first so we built the
greatest economy in history we closed it
down because of the china plague when
the plague came in we closed it down
which was very hard around
psychologically to do i don't think we
should close it down and he was wrong
and again two million people would be
dead now
still 204 000 people is too much one
person is too much
should have never happened from china
but what happened is
we closed it down and now we're
reopening and we're doing records
we had 10.4 million people in a
four-month period that we've
put back into the workforce that's a
record the likes of which nobody's ever
seen
before and he wants to close down the he
will shut it down again
he will destroy this country you know a
lot of people say it between
the party supports it about this
this yeah looks like he's a death store
and he sounds like it too
kamala harris said under a harris
administration she didn't even correct
me
she didn't even have the courtesy of
correcting herself
you know i remember back in the days of
you know what can can desires be
resurrected to give that woman a fat lip
oh i don't know what to do boom zoom
send her back to at least her place
the vp she's on the under card of that
ticket she said that under her
administration it's just
we're at this point where it is unreal
they want to shut down the economy in
purpose again
michigan and a couple of others you
gotta open these states up
it's not fair you're talking about
almost it's like being in prison
and you look at what's going on with
divorce look at what's going on with
alcoholism and drugs it's a
very very sad thing and he'll close down
the whole country this guy will close
down the whole country
and destroy our country our country is
coming back
incredibly well setting records as it
does it
we don't need somebody to come in and
say let's shut it down
all right you're two minutes sir we're
now moved to you
as i as i said posing the question the
president says it's a v-shape recovery
you say it's a k-shaped
recovery thank you very much
another billionaires of ray have made
another 300
billion dollars because of his
profligate tax
uh
you folks living in scranton and
claymont and all the small towns
you haven't been to scranton in 40
something years
this guy paid well total of 750 in taxes
right now sir i understand you've agreed
to the two minutes so please let him
have it do i get my time back
the fact is that everything in fact
worked on this in a way that he's going
to be the first president united states
the average
growth in the united states under donald
trump in his three years is
five thousand dollars it is more
significant than ever
in modern american history that never
happened under barack obama and it's
even more significant for african
americans those people who are
that is something that people need to
know people and also by the way we're
talking about trade agreements people
who've been putting in the economy
joe biden supported nafta joe biden
supported the trans-pacific partnership
yeah and donald trump did away with
those and a big part of this that no one
ever talks about when they talk about
fighting for 15.
you know i was reading up on some of
these rules here is uh some key points
from the united states mexico canada
agreement
requires 75 of the vehicles parts be
made of one of those from one of those
countries
and it requires more vehicle parts and
labor take place
uh by workers earning more than 16 an
hour
this is what he does this is how he
helps support the american worker and
you see record wage growth
it affects you you have paid less in
taxes and seen more wage growth joe
biden has to lie about that because he
knows that americans are experiencing it
safely you know they were going to give
his administration going to give the
teachers and school
students masks and then they decided no
couldn't do that because it's not a
national emergency
not a national emergency they've done
nothing to help that small
business don't come back nothing they're
closing one in six is now gone
you ought to get on the job and take
care of the needs of the american people
what did you do and say do your time
no i'm not hurting wait hold on hold on
nope no you should do something
let me give you some specifics the
hashtag is crowder debate stream and
it's crowded
stream you get twenty dollars off if you
join mug club at liverpool.com we
haven't had our stream banned tonight so
that's yeah
what they've done in new york people
want their places open
they want to get back to their lives
people they'll be careful safe but they
want their schools
i'm the one that brought back football
by the way i brought back big ten
football
america and not wrong i'm very happy to
do it yeah but
football isn't coming very hard proud of
me and
you're not gonna get it gentlemen your
economic plans going forward in a moment
but first mr president
i thought it lived this way where
american football is gayer than
soccer the year you were elected
president and 2017.
it's almost all over as president that
you paid
750 a year it's harder
each of those years
a lot of other taxes but i'm asking you
the specific question
is it true that you paid 750 in federal
income taxes each of those questions is
it true
is that i'll come back to this question
millions of dollars of income tax
racial matters
donald trump only paid 38 million in
taxes listen there's some years where
you pay
tens of millions hundreds of millions
and there's some years where you have
losses as a business but there's more to
it than that but
that's what i said is it true that's an
important note on that question go to
the board of elections
there's a 118 page or so report that
says everything i have
every bank i have i'm totally under
leveraged because the assets are
extremely good
and we have a very we have a we i built
a specific question i don't
know money i understand all of that i
just take it from other people
no mr
american taxpayers in 2016 and 2017.
millions of dollars
you paid millions of dollars of dollars
billions of dollars and you'll get to
see it
and you'll get to see it but let me just
chris let me just
say when what when will you get to see
when joe biden says
in july in july i was a private
developer i was a private business
people
like every other private person unless
they're stupid
they go through the laws and that's what
it is it's true he passed a tax bill
that gave us all these anyone here
trying to pay taxes and they owe them
a few hundred million dollars
to be fair much like the presidency
kamala harris is the main trustee
oh yeah i do want look
the tax code that made him and you
put him in a position that he pays less
tax than a school teacher
make them on the money in school okay
here's what i will say
he has no substance here i realized i
woke up today
and i had a song in my head but i was
just going wait a second we talked about
this about tax codes and americans and
employers and yeah who understands what
how many people have actually had to pay
payroll tax versus you know social
security okay
income tax versus corporate tax and i
realized we skipped past people out
there
this came from the new york times who
had the russia collusion story
and they said they had the taxes and now
they said well by the way it didn't
confirm anything with russia and then i
realized wait a second
do we have any confirmation do we have
any legitimate source we have any
corroboration this is true
at all none none so i don't even know
why we're addressing it and i swear to
you you might even turn it i woke up
and this is how it came to me i'm not i
had a song and you know what it was
no this is i woke up and in my head i
was like my head popped off the pillow
and i just watched the wedding singer
and it was it all was
[ __ ] the new york times a joke
and when i think of you biden
i hope you [ __ ] show oh oh wow
that was in my head all day and then i
spent hours
going get the music in your soul
confirmation for the story for the new
york times
and it's made it into a presidential was
the
debate
of fake news exactly on every news
channel by the way the news channel that
said that fox news has
no journalistic standards whatsoever
they don't confirm their stories before
they go to air
right the cnn that's the people that
have been pushing this harder than
anyone else can someone confirmed to me
that he got that from the montreal
planet hollywood from the beetlejuice
wardrobe that tie on joe biden
it would create an additional one
trillion dollars in economic growth
because
are you running for president or a tim
burton barbershop quartet
the federal government spends 600
billion dollars here on everything from
ships to steel to buildings and the like
and under my proposal we're going to
make sure that every penny of that
has to be made by a company respectively
so i'm talking about taxes not
spending well twice by the way i'm going
to eliminate a significant number of the
tax i'm going to make the
the the corporate tax 28 it shouldn't be
21 percent
you have 19. you said you're going to
eliminate
because you in fact passed that that was
your tax report i got it done and you
know
mr president let me pick up on that you
would continue
your free market approach lower taxes
more
deregulation not lower
more jobs were created a million and a
half more jobs
that in the first three years of your
presidency they had the slowest
recovery since 90 economic recovery
since 1929
it was the slowest recovery also they
took over something that was down here
all you had to do was turn on the lights
and you pick up a lot
but they had the slowest economic
recovery since 1929 let me tell you
about this
when the stock market goes up that means
jobs
it may not play well my god with your
ideas you want to terminate my tax
my taxes i i'll tell you what you'll
lose half of the companies that have
poured in here yes will leave
and plenty of companies that are already
here they'll leave for other places have
they will leave
and you will have a price
the worst recession short of a
depression in american history
i was asked to bring it back we were
able to have i
got to say something important any
person who's done investing
in the last three years investing in
real estate invested in stocks invested
in the economy
has said during the entirety of the
trump presidency yeah
no doubt the economy came back that's
how the cycle works but they've been
saying every year since trump was
president
well it's going to go down next year
well it's definitely got to be next
really telling but it's not they claim
they inherited a bad economy from george
bush
but they never say we right now he
hasn't said we passed on the economy to
trump he's saying ah the economy is
terrible
they go to covet yeah so before combat
they tried to say oh
you know what actually he's only doing
well because of our economy because
apparently there's a lag of
give or take four years give or take a
term yeah exactly but now they're
pivoting to ah see look the economy is
bad because of kovid yeah
well hold on a second what happened
wasn't it your economy they know that
they can claim no credit i can tell you
this anecdotally
two more hires bryce and angela yeah
yeah period it's a small business
two more hires because we can project
yeah well you know you're just not on
the payroll close yeah you're on
ice what is that email like is that a
lie
well yeah the numbers that you see in
your account it's just me doing a screen
share with a fake bank
itself mr vice president
and so you take a look at what he's
actually done he's done very little
a lot of trade deals are the same way he
talks about these
trade deals you know he talks about the
art of the deal i'm trying
to [ __ ] i'm sorry this is the biggest
contrast between the two administration
this guy supported nafta this guy
supported tpp
donald trump scrapped them how do you
think you have the lowest approval
rating
of middle class working american voters
you screwed them and donald trump the
republican has rewritten the electoral
map
it's not even close you ship jobs
overseas
and you increased taxes on the business
owners who were employing those
americans
the guy to your right my left on this
screen i assume i don't know the spatial
awareness of how it's going with the
constitution written in the background
that joe biden likely ignored
the fact is he knows what has been going
on
he has lowered taxes on american
businesses and
forced them to meet prerequisites if
they want other tax breaks this is a
good thing too
he really hasn't had to do all that much
as far as tariffs he's just had to say
hey listen
you are going to be rewarded if you
employ more americans who make 16
an hour or more for american auto
manufacturing you are going to make more
if you bring jobs back here to american
church we're going to encourage it
and by the way even china all of a
sudden was like oh you know
maybe you're right yeah maybe we were
wrong
i am now considering removing my pekka
from your reef oh wow his position he is
uh
48 that was from their prime minister
well the 48th year is the chance i
thought it was distasteful
yeah but that's how their prime
minister's talk over there well hey you
know sometimes yeah
what you're going to say president
everyone dictator
matter is discredited shortly mr
president who testified
under oath so let me ask you this go
ahead mr
i'm listening to you people under you've
got three and a half testified
he testified under oath in his
administration said i did my
job and i did it very well who they are
every well i'll give you the list of the
people who are testing
they've you've already fired most of
them because they did a good job some
people don't well
here's it yeah
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this
hey let me tell you something
wow
there's a deal we want to talk about
families
and ethics i don't want to do that all
right i mean his family we could talk
about i don't want to do it his family
is our
family my family just a fortune
coming down and helping us with
government
donald trump and his family have
foregone fortune by working for
government
which by the way if they're saying
donald trump hasn't paid anything in
taxes he sure
is shitty at funneling money to his own
entities as president of the united
states which was the scandal they said
he should believe
is it hold on a second is that he's such
a crappy business person he's never paid
taxes
or he's this cunning evil genius who's
become president so that he can increase
the value of his businesses because the
years are talking about him not paying
taxes he was president
you gotta pick one sir with a billion
dollars if you get that
absolutely you know what you're waiting
not true you're doing it you're going to
do that okay true
gentlemen i hate to raise my voice but
it seems to me why shouldn't i be
different than the two of you so here's
the date good point
we have uh five six segments that was
chris paul's
race we're going to go to the next walk
all over him we are going to have i'm
not
i'm surprised sneaker
anything footprints want i'm going to
ask a question about race but if you
want to answer
oh god let's go ahead joe biden please
do mention that you oppose
desegregation because you didn't want
your children to grow up
in a racial jungle confirmed by snokes
jungle biden and snopes and they really
didn't want to confirm that [ __ ]
well less than he's or less than plenty
no really we got to just let him answer
please continue on
the issue of race vice president biden
you say that president
trump's response to the violence in
charlottesville
three years ago when he talked about
verifying
people on both sides was what directly
led you toward to launch this run for
president oh yeah sure
president trump you have often said that
you believe you have done
more for black americans than any
president observable possible
perception i mean i
over the next four years vice president
biden you go first
it's about equity inequality it's about
decency
it's about the constitution and we have
never walked away from
trying to quite require equity for
everyone equality for the whole
why did you draft the 1994 crime bill
joe never accomplished it but we've
never
segregation saying that you didn't want
your children to quote grow up in a
racial jungle confirmed by snow
you racist [ __ ] oh boy i will in a
bet that if we go into your closet we'll
find a stack of white hoods like it's a
returning costume like the captain of
the incredible the cool cost clan a
young woman got killed just like people
haven't seen
what he thought he said only it's a
white hat with a cone on it and two eyes
lips
no no he did define people on both sides
arguments
there was a peaceful protest in front of
the white house i don't think joe
biden's a racist i think he's interested
had the military to use tear gas on them
so you could walk
across to a church and hold up a bible
and then
what happened after that the bishop of
that very church said
that it was the disgrace the general who
was with him
who was a well-known liberal activist
i'm pretty confident he's just reading
headlines from like
young persons with no facts that's his
research yeah
his his debate partner his mock debate
partner
was an angry pink mohawk lesbian yeah in
fact
you talk about helping out i don't laugh
because that's probably true one
in 1 000 african americans has been
killed but because of the cona
the coronavirus and if he doesn't do
something quickly by the end of the year
one in 500 will have been killed one in
500 african-americans
this man what are you talking about uh
right
is there a 0.25 mortality rate for black
americans
i mean that's kind of high look at what
he talks about
you have to look at what he did and what
he did has been described
he's talking about he could be he's
talking about black americans in prison
president trump where he put them
because it was not grounded for
crime there was kept in there he's like
a tag team free indentured servitude
labor for the state then i guess he has
a point super predator that's one for
[ __ ] american super predators and
they've never forgotten it
they've never forgotten it jefferson
yeah oh you said that
and they called you super predator and
i'm letting people out of jail now that
you have treated the african-american
non-violent drug offensive population
anyone out there thinks that non-violent
drug offenders shouldn't be locked up
your choice couldn't be more
clear it's been almost his own diet
if you look at the polls i'm doing
better than any republican has done in a
long time that's true because they saw
what
you did you call them super predators
and you've called them worse than that
because you look back at your testimony
over the years you've called them a lot
worse than that as far as the church is
concerned
and as far as the generals are concerned
we just got the support of 200
mil 250 military leaders and generals
total support law enforcement almost
every law enforcement
group in the united states i have
florida that's really going to sting
because they're big ohio i have every
excuse me portland the sheriff just came
out today and he said i support
president trump does that count as
evidence any law enforcement you can't
even say that
is he the sheriff the black lady of
portland or was that they must be the
second
police commissioner
why don't you say the words law
enforcement because you know what if
they called us in portland
we would put out that fire in a half an
hour but they won't do it because
they're run by radical left democrats
if you look at chicago if you look at
any place you want to look seattle
they heard we were coming in the
following day and they put up their
hands and we got back seattle
minneapolis we got it back joe because
we believe in law and order but you
don't
the top ten cities in which oh this is
bad for joe and he's here
duck face democrats in many cases
radical left and they've got you wrapped
around their fingertips
to a point where you don't want to say
anything about their attraction
and i'll tell you what the people of
this place he had lived but they were
stoned
by hillary clinton and you're afraid to
even say it all right
i want to i want to return to the
question of race
he was trying to try to go through the
inventory in his brain for something
that he couldn't find
aside you said it raises the question
quote whether
justice could be equally applied in
america do you believe
that there is a separate but unequal
system of justice first
this is what job scout did yeah there's
just systemic
injustice in this country in education
and work and
in oh wait in law enforcement
accountability and the way in which it's
enforced
but look the vast majority of police
officers are good
decent honorable men and women they risk
their lives every day to take care of us
but there are some bad apples and when
they occur oh i thought bad apples was
the worst thing to say
you just have to be home you can't then
and we're going to work this out we're
going to work this out so we change no
specifics
we're gonna work this out
cops aren't happy you're asking me
questions to george floyd
unexpected cops aren't happy to see dog
face pony boy
what do some push-ups stop [ __ ] but
violence and response is never
appropriate never appropriate
peaceful protest is violence he's not
going to comment responsible for
violence
when they run
i promise we're going to get to the
issue of law and order in a moment
this month your administration he didn't
come back
again
we're going to get to that in a second
right we will yeah that's true
absolutely like listen you guys you guys
will each have time to answer the
questions
good that's what i wanted and do you
believe that there is systemic racism in
this country sir
no i ended it because it's racist i
ended it because a lot of people were
complaining that they were
asked to do things that were absolutely
insane
that it was a radical uh revolution that
was taking place
in our military talking about the
training in our schools
all over the place and you know it's
racist everybody else which by the way
every single white person is sensitivity
training
if you were a certain person you had no
status in life it was sort of a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick ideas
and and really they were teaching people
to hate our country
and i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to allow that to happen
good job we have to go back that's the
truth of this country
they were teaching people that our
country is a horrible place it's a
racist place and they were teaching
people to hate ourselves and critical
race theory
black liberation theology if you look at
what uh what
barack obama subscribed to with derek
bell if you look at these beliefs it is
this is the idea of implicit bias it's
you are racist if you are white
ergo the united states is a racist
country activity people have to be made
aware
of what other people feel like what like
you were made aware when you opposed
desegregation because you didn't want
your kids to grow up in a oh make sure i
get this
racial jungle according to snopes yeah
i don't think he's a racist um he just
plays one on tv
he does a really good job a sense of
self-esteem
it's a little bit like how this guy and
and his friends
looked down on so many people they look
down their nose on people like
irish catholics like me and grew up in
scranton
who's looking down on african americans
who are of a different
faith they look down on people who are a
different color
in fact we're all americans the only
ones i've got to say i don't think we've
talked about people who try and avoid
issues and not get the specifics um i've
never seen it so egregious tonight with
joe biden
but this guy who looks down is there any
that he looks down on irish catholics is
he just reading another
another uh headline from huffpo that
says behind closed doors
uh donald trump mocks christian voters
he just nominated a catholic to the
supreme court you asked
your bumbling demented circus monkey
last i checked it wasn't the uh
republicans
throwing shade at her for being a
catholic either right
no there was a new york times you also
have a completely uncorroborated
unconfirmed story about donald trump's
taxes so
like you about law haven't and order
are you in favor of law and order i'm in
favor of law you follow are you in favor
of law and order
what do you say phoney who's his lawyer
let him take him on the bike
and the fact of the matter is violent
crime went down 17
15 in our administration it's gone up on
his watch went down he's much more he
has all right
we're not you're right that went down
much more up until black lives matter
yeah and you can actually look at that
spike entirely due to
leftist cities what is it uh san
francisco saw 100
increase was it in murder rape or
violent crime new york saw
several hundred percent increase in
violent crime murder rape
arson so yeah you know it's it's one of
those things that it does matter it does
matter because
this is where americans need to
understand there's constitutional
authority there are roles of the federal
government
and then there are roles of the state
government and the president cannot
like he and he's respected those
boundaries by not sitting in the
national guard unless by request
right but if you look at these states
and you look at these cities
portland new york uh detroit seattle all
of these major cities chicago
where these protests have gotten
increasingly violent these are under
democratic rule where they refuse to
enforce law order
and you have seen several hundred
percent increase
in violent crimes similarly bill clinton
tried to claim that he was the one who
oversaw a reduction in crime although he
kind of had to play both sides of the
fence because he tried to push the
assault weapons ban
implying that there was increased crime
but violent crime went down under bill
clinton
it is almost entirely attributable i
think it was two-thirds or at least
one-third just to giuliani in new york
yeah exactly
this is not 1950. all these dog whistles
on racism don't work anymore
suburbs oh my god is this is this a
buzzfeed boldly
this is surprising to me because even
though he's trying to not be pinned on
policies joe biden
you can see his retic is the rhetoric is
increasingly social justice yeah
yeah absolutely very much so suburbs are
interesting i do want to talk about this
issue of law and organizations
recommendations aren't in trouble yet
because they're well armed that's true
task force that's right you talked about
quote reimagining
policing first of all what does
reimagining
policing mean and do you what is the
idea it means
look what i support is the police
having the opportunity to deal with the
problems they face
and i'm not totally opposed to defunding
the police officers
whoa police local police say i'm not
right
his budget calls for 400.00
to have someone with them as a
psychologist or psychiatrist
to keep them from having to use force
people down one of the examples of jacob
blake where they showed up and the guy
was chasing a cop with a knife
can you imagine if a social worker who
wanted to ask him about his relationship
with his mother would have handled it
let's just talk for a minute okay let's
talk they're talking about
christmas that's not what that's talking
about defunding the police that is not
true
he doesn't have any law with his support
he has no
law enforcement that's not true almost
that's not look
that is absolutely true name one group
that came out and supported you
go ahead i think we have time
one law enforcement group that came back
and i think i'm going to i'm going to
this last place
and i want to get to another subject
which is the
you say that people who commit crimes
should be held
accountable the question i have though
is as the democratic nominee and earlier
tonight you said that you
are the democratic party right now have
you ever called the democratic
uh democratic governor of oregon and
said
hey you got to stop this bring in the
national guard
do whatever it takes but you stop the
days and months of violence better
suited going into oregon and saying
bring
it out i am a former vice president i've
made it clear
i've made it clear in my public
statement the answer is no the violence
should be prosecuted
it should be prosecuted and anyone who
commits it but you've never called for
the people
the leader excuse me sir you had never
doing a good job
he's doing a pretty good job in oregon
to call us
bring in the national guard and knock
off a hundred days of riots
they can in fact take care of it if he
just stay out of the way
whoa they're not taking care of it look
at over 2 billion dollars in damages
30 people dead over a thousand officer
casualties
14 000 arrests and the only time they
step up is because the proud boys want
to drive by at a couple of trucks with
some american flags
and maybe a couple of paintball guns i
won't lie that's just a good
old-fashioned saturday
the point is here they have done nothing
billions of dollars in damages
you were talking about dozens of people
dead well
this is a per if you are a black person
in the united states right now and you
are living and let's be honest there
aren't many in seattle but let's talk
about
chicago let's talk about new york and
you are seeing your neighborhood
destroyed if you're one of the 80 plus
percent of black americans who support
at least as much police presence as now
if not more which by the way is
reflected in every single poll
you need to see right now you have a
former vice president who by the way
said
he didn't want to support desegregation
because he didn't want his kids being
raised in a
racial jungle according to snopes right
now is saying hey
let your shots be burnt down let your
david dorns be shot
let your young show let your schools be
burned down to the ground
because we can't have donald trump step
in enough we can't have a national guard
if this will be fixed if the federal
government stays out of it
it is just like the exact opposite if
you wanted to protect the most
vulnerable among us with covet right the
exact opposite
of what you would do is quarantine the
sick you would you were quarantining the
health you would quarantine the sick you
would quarantine
old people you would quarantine sick
people this is the exact
opposite in the same sense that he
doesn't understand the role of the
federal government the role of the
federal government is to step
in when local government cannot keep its
citizens american citizens
safe from either external threats or
internal threats so he's willing to step
into your state
and tell you which kind of healthcare
you have to purchase he's willing to
step into your state and tell you which
kind of a business you
have to patron if he if you want to
receive some kind of a tax break but he
is not willing
to have the federal government step in
under its legitimate purview into a
state where american citizens
are dying and the police are overrun to
help
you minority american citizens there you
go you hear this guy
has no idea as to what the actual
parameters of government are
there when there are no principles
you're seeing it fall apart tonight he
cannot provide specific answers
and when he does they're the opposite of
what you have the authority to do if you
want to say donald trump's an
authoritarian
the guy on this stage let me get this
straight and then we'll go back to the
debates i'm sorry
the guy in this stage we're supposed to
believe is an authoritarian
is the guy who by joe biden's own
accusations
lowered taxes yeah right supported
freedom of speech
employed more americans encourage
businesses as opposed to actually just
punishing or putting on terrorists
encouraged americans to employ
encouragement businesses to employ more
americans yeah it encourages americans
to be able to
uh exercise their second amendment
rights and is going to appoint a supreme
court justice that will support those
as well and has stayed out of i think
lost count because of this rap on my
head
has actually stayed out of these states
where american citizens are dying and he
would be well within his right to deploy
the national guard to some capacitor the
american military
in all its power until they ask for it
that's the guy who's the authoritarian
he's bad at it the guy who would every
single turn
has allowed you more freedom and more
rights sounds like a dictator
yeah it might be murky on the definition
there but by the way i just i have one
the first thing dictators do is come in
and lower that corporate tax rate and
individual tax rate
and have more freedoms guaranteed to all
americans i have a quick question for
joe biden
what exactly did president trump do to
get in the way
you're saying that these states could
handle the problem if he would just get
out of the way what exactly disqualifies
you from filling in for chris wallace
gerald
would you win a golf tournament i'm just
confused here like he didn't
he didn't get in the way in the first
place he didn't go into a place
that was in the way is that helena
bonham carter ty biden
a fixing of the the va
which was a mess under him 308 000
people died because they didn't have
proper health care he
was a mess and we now got a 91 approval
rating
at the va our vets we take care of our
vets but we've rebuilt our military
the job that we've done and i'll tell
you something some people say maybe the
most important
by the end of the first term i'll have
approximately
300 federal judges and court of appeals
judges 300
and hopefully three great supreme court
judges
justices that is a record i've never the
likes of i know very few people
there's no contrast between the rest of
his face yeah i think it's all the same
[ __ ] he's sucking all the blood
from available it's like yoko ono's ass
horizontally on a face
there is no actually it's just a crash
just don't do that it's just a crevice
128 the same stuff like if i were to go
freehand mountain climbing that's where
i'd sort of leverage my knees
yeah that's a great thing right now
128 you can't be a good president
you can't be a good vice president but i
want to thank you because it gives us
almost
it'll probably be above that number by
the end of this term
300 judges it's a record looking at both
your records
why should voters elect you president as
opposed to president trump
you have two minutes uninterrupted under
this president we become weaker
sicker what poor how more divided
we become weaker with no major wars i
think donald trump is the only president
to not start under armed conflict as
opposed to you who are dropping drone
strikes like a new mixtape
economy and he caused a recession oh
really with regard to
being a deposit when he had the best
economy ever
you said that was the result of obama
despite the fact that he never saw those
unemployment rates or labor force
participation rates
in all eight years you guys tried to
claim credit and now you're saying need
to blame for the recession
okay let's keep this in mind when the
economy rebounds and by the way it's
rebounded faster than they anticipated
because
they were preparing for the debate with
worst case scenario
12 percent unemployment right going to
the election exactly it's already below
9.
he hasn't been set up he never keeps his
words
all right go ahead so thirdly
we're poor the billionaires have gotten
much much more wealthy
by a tune of over 300
you don't need to fight for 15 anymore
because more americans make
significantly more than 15
than ever up that number when we were in
office
16 violence
and with regard to more divided the
nation
can't stay divided we can't be this way
and speaking of my son the way you talk
about the military
the way you talk about them being losers
and being
kind of oh my gosh
this is a man who's running for office
keep in mind people out there who say
well you know what i'm uh i'm not
pro-social justice warrior but i'm not a
republican i'm a classical liberal
this is a guy who is reading slate and
salon headlines the website that by the
way repeatedly support pedophile
salon.com
i'm a pedophile but i'm not a monster
they actually denigrated us because we
said uh
if you're a pedophile you're likely a
monster these are the web he's reading
headlines from these websites
joe biden right now there is no evidence
that donald trump has ever called troops
losers and suckers and there are over 10
accounts including people who were in
those rooms saying
that's absolutely untrue their email uh
verification that you can see
screenshots right now that prove
it was the the main story for this when
it started that spurred it was a weather
event where you couldn't actually attend
uh an event it's it's it's
bolton bone wrote a whole book the guy
that takes a steaming dump on trump and
he even
said like you know yeah i don't have i
don't really have any integrity left but
uh i'm going to try and save a shred of
it that's not true
i think he brought up hunters he's
already been he did it
we both we've already been through this
i think the american people would rather
hear
about more substantial objections well
you know
as the moderator sir i'm going to make a
judgment call here three and a half
million
mitt romney on that committee said it
wasn't worth taxpayers money that
reporter was written for political
reasons you know
i'd like to talk about climate change
romney's a wiener head and you know it
the by the way you also foreign mitt
romney was racist
back then [ __ ] they have displaced
hundreds of thousands of people when
state officials there blamed the fires
on climate change mr president you said
i don't think the science is disgusting
over your four years
you know how you pulled the us out of
the u.s accord
you have rolled back a number of
obamacare iron metal
you know i'm going to chase that skirt
out of here you guys know about the
science of climate change
four years to confront us crystal clean
water
and air i want beautiful clean air we
have now the lowest carbon
if you look at our numbers right now we
are
doing phenomenally but i haven't
destroyed our businesses
our businesses there's the balancing
commission are you going to destroy you
look at
the paris accord it was a disaster this
is climate change
we have fires in california which we've
had since california was california
because our businesses are doing well as
far as the fires are concerned
you need forest management in addition
to everything else yeah the forest
floors
are loaded up with trees dead trees that
are years old and they're like tinder
and leaves and everything else you drop
a
i believe that we have to do everything
we can to have
immaculate air immaculate water and do
whatever else we can that's good you
know we're planting a billion trees
the big tree projections and it's very
good i got to tell you that
it's underserved how much republican
support conservation house gas emissions
if you had forest management forest
management
you wouldn't be getting those calls you
know in europe they live their forest
cities they call forest cities
they maintain their forest they manage
their forests
i was with the head of a major country
it's a forest city
he said sir we have trees that are far
more they they ignite much easier than
california
there shouldn't be that problem i spoke
with the governor about it i'm getting
along very well with the government
why have you rolled back the obama clean
power plan which
limited carbon emissions and power
plants why have you released it because
it was driving
energy prices through the sky why have
you relaxed fuel economy
standards that are going to create more
pollution
is the car is much less expensive and
it's a much safer car
and when you're talking about a tiny
difference
in california wildfires at least triple
the number of cars purchased we have the
old slugs out there that are 10 12 years
old
if you did that the car would be safer
it would be much cheaper but
they've simply take a lot of cars off
the market because people would be able
to afford a car now
so and by the way we're going to see how
that turns out but a lot of people agree
with me many people
the car has gotten so expensive because
they have computers all over the place
for an extra one of the drinking rules
don't don't die on the stream
and i'm okay with electric cars too i
think i'm all for electric cars i've
given big incentives for electric cars
but what they've done in california is
just crazy
vice president biden i'd like you to to
respond to the president's climate
change record but i also want to ask you
about a concern you proposed two
trillion dollars in green
jobs you talk about new limits not
abolishing but new limits on fracking
ending the use of fossil fuels to
generate electricity by 2035
and zero net emission of greenhouse
gases by 2050.
the president says a lot of these things
would tank the economy and cost millions
of jobs he's absolutely wrong
number one number two if in
during our administration the recovery
act i was able to i was in charge able
to bring down the cost
of renewable energy to cheaper than or
as cheap as
coal and gas and oil nobody's going to
build another
affordable uh and really realistic
making sure that we can move 500 000
charging stations
and all of the highways that we're going
to be building in the future
we're going to build a economy that in
fact is going to provide for
the ability us to take four million
buildings and make sure that they in
fact
are weatherized in a way that in fact
we're going to let them speak
they'll admit significantly less take
everything that you just mentioned
not even close to what elon musk
as far as infrastructure as far as uh
spearheading the market as far as
innovation
energy what you need is a president by
20 steps out of the way for more proof
who's the leader in the electric car
space right now uh it's got to be tested
it would be something yeah something
based uh with tesla they've
moved their factory from california to
texas
yeah because california is a little
petri dish and the providence policies
i will texas is a little petri dish
foreign
instead of doing something about that i
would be gathering up and making sure we
had to come
the countries of the world coming up
with 20 billion dollars say here's 20
billion dollars
stop stop tearing down
the forest and if you don't then you're
going to imagine a moment significantly
you just watched
fern gully consequently what about the
argument no that was avatar
basically says that you have to balance
environmental interests
and economic interests and he's drawn
his line
well he hadn't drawn a line he still for
example make sure that we he wants to
make sure that
methane is not a problem we can you can
now emit more methane without it being a
problem
this is a guy who says that you don't
have to have mileage standards for
automobiles that exist now
this is the guy who says that well the
fact that
it's all true here's something about the
green new deal and it's not 2 billion
or 20 billion as you said it's 100
trillion dollars i'm talking about
they want to rip down buildings and
rebuild the building
it's the most redundant
where two car systems are out where they
want to take out the cows too
you know that's not true either right no
this is a this is a 100
that's more money than our country could
make in a hundred years it would not be
the case all right let me let me let me
see because i actually wait a minute
sorry i've
never seen any presidential candidates
studying your plan right and it has been
joe biden
four million buildings weatherizing two
million hounds over four years building
one and a half
million energy efficient homes
so the question becomes some the
president is saying i
think some people who support the
president would say that sounds
like it's going to cost a lot of money
and hurt the economy what it's going to
do it's going to create
thousands and millions of jobs good
paying jobs let them finish sir
he doesn't know how to do that 100
billion the fact is it's going to create
millions of good paying jobs and these
tax incentives to people
for people to weatherize which he wants
to get get rid of
it's going to grip the economy donald
trump is kind of lurching behind her
to do the entire evening has been one
and three dealers
he said i'm surprised i never
is clean by the way we all know we're in
better shape we spend
billions of dollars now billions of
dollars
on floods hurricanes rising seas
we're in real trouble look what's
happening just in the midwest with these
there we go storms that come through and
wipe out here
record crop yields the most temperate
climate we've ever had
and uh and the highest great lake levels
in
centuries don't you mean those are good
things which by the way in 2017 you said
would be gone
you said that they would be gone by the
year
years of heavy rainfall for the great
lakes just to return to normal levels
and i said we have record high great
that was your administration they just
crammed the 20 years into two that's
what he's asking right here cherries are
the [ __ ] of the fruit
they're very very difficult to yield and
we're dumping record cherries in
michigan
he made a couple of statements because
of our records 100
million dollars
he said i said something about the
military he and his friends made it up
and then they went with it i never said
it okay
the final question is i can't remember
which of all i can't remember
i can't remember myself but freudian
slip was never so slippery
and about this question of what it's
going to cost the the economy
and the idea of what your environmental
chinese the green new deal
will pay for itself as well oh my god he
is doubling that
for those who haven't seen a great
polluting place watch the video where i
read the entire green new deal before
to post support five pages
and it gives the government control over
everything everything
it includes the words social justice in
there
and by the way in social justice what
does that mean oh we only had five pages
to write this yeah
the fact that a presidential you cannot
be a moderate liberal you cannot be
someone who says
i'm a classical liberal and vote for a
man who supports the green new deal
that reads like a slate article really
the the shortened version because it's
only five pages
what are you prepared to do over the
next five
plus weeks because it'll not only be to
election day but also
counting some ballots mail-in ballots
after election day
what are you prepared to do to reassure
the american people that the next
president
will be the legitimate winner of this
election
in this final how about you call out
that guy from texas uh
who was one of the 137 charges brought
for massive voter fraud
his own homeland security director as
well as the fbi director says there is
no evidence at all that mail and ballots
are a source of of being manipulated and
cheating
they still have projects for georgia new
jersey
because of michigan new york california
pennsylvania and texas all of which have
been verified by a court of law
a judge's order or an unbiased state
governing uh
election committee in person are able to
we did a whole segment on it i don't
want to interrupt them but
[ __ ] socially distance the polls are
open on time
and their polls stay open until the
votes are counted and this is all about
six weeks after election people from
voting
because he's trying to con to scare
people into thinking
that it's not going to be legitimate
show up and vote
you will determine the outcome of this
election vote
vote vote so you'll accept the results
early in
vote in person vote whatever way is the
best way for you
because you will not stop you right from
being able to determine the outcome of
this
vote for your dead meanwhile
don't forget after this we're gonna be
taking some questions i gotta tell you
the biggest questions i have it's not
necessarily the one that's debate
but did you hear a single plank
on any kind of platform on any issue
from joe biden other than i hate this
guy over here it was all headlines say a
single plank
yeah a plank on a platform that you're
talking about yeah oh plank on the
platform
just make sure you understand you come
on
that's a good point to determine what
this country's going to look like
for years is it going to change any
major years of these lies
mr president two minutes so when i
listened to joe
talking about a transition there's been
no transition from when i won i won that
election
and if you look at crooked hillary
clinton if you look at all of the
different people
there was no transition because they
came after me trying to do a coup
they came after me spying on my campaign
they started from the day i won
and even before i won from the day i
came down the escalator with our first
lady
they were a disaster they were disgraced
to our country
and we've caught them we've caught them
all we've got it all on tape we've
caught them all and by the way you gave
the idea for the logan
act against general flynn you better
take a look at that yeah
and president obama was sitting in the
office he knew about it too so don't
tell me about a free
transition as far as the ballots are
concerned it's a disaster
a solicited ballot okay
solicit it is okay you're still
listening you're asking they send it
back you send it back
i did that if you have an unsolicited
they're sending millions of ballots all
over the country
there's fraud they found him in creeks
they found some with the name trump just
happened to have the name
trump just the other day in a waste
paper basket they're being sent all over
the place
they sent two in a democrat area they
sent out a thousand ballots everybody
got two ballots
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen the other thing
it's nice on november 3rd you're
watching and you see who won the
election
and i think we're going to do well
because people are really happy with the
job we've done
but you know what we won't know we might
not know for months
because these ballots are going to be
all over take a look at what happened
take a look at what happened amazing new
jersey take a look at what happened in
virginia and other places
they're not losing two percent one
percent which by the way is
and can you imagine where they say uh
you have to have your ballot in by
november 10th
november 10th that means that's seven
days
after the election in theory doesn't
matter should have been announced okay
we have major states with that sir all
run by democrats says two minutes
all run by democrats president trump
you're going to be able to continue you
have been charging for months and
mail-in balloting is going to be a
disaster you say it's rigged
that it's going to lead to fraud and
there's fraud and also
the system from the competence to a
billion people
we already have verifiable evidence to
the tune of tens of thousands
of fraud and one to the tune of millions
that's their ballots by me let's be
clear
42 million unsolicited ballots will be
sent out to americans
that cannot be verified that cannot be
counted in time for election
that has never happened including a
justice barrier two issues fraud
and incompetence and i just realized
i don't think well i hope we don't need
them in terms of the election itself
but for the ballots i think so because
what's happening is incredible i just
heard i read today where at least
one percent of the ballots for 2016 were
invalidated they they take them we don't
like them we don't like them
i'm asking you about the fact that
millions of people you go and reload
you go and vote but like they think like
they used to in the
millions of people you either do chris a
solicited ballot where you're sending it
in they're sending it back and you're
sending
they have mailman with lots of it did
you see what's going on take a look at
west virginia mailman selling the
ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country there is no this is
not there is no this is not going to end
with a video
vice president five states
for the last decade or more five
including two republican states
and you don't have to solicit the ballot
it's sent to you
it's sent to your home it's true what
we're saying is they've developed
even if you don't live there so what
you're saying is in a pandemic we can
just go ahead we can barely get
essential services done but we can
create an entirely new system in states
that have never done it
and there won't be a problem in one of
the most important elections in our
history
it's about time for you to get back to
it the home
vice president biden the biggest problem
in fact over the years with mail-in
voting
has not been fraud historically it has
been
that sizable numbers sometimes hundreds
of thousands of ballots are thrown out
because they have not been properly
michigan fraud 8468 ballots pennsylvania
which had recently 934 felony charges
brought in texas
in georgia over a thousand residents
voted twice in new jersey a judge even
ruled and ordered a new election because
a sitting city councilman
engaged in election fraud by over 800
votes that couldn't be counted in
california
more than a hundred thousand ballots
rejected 27 000 of them because
signatures were not included or did not
match meaning
fraudulent uh new york hundred thousand
brooklyn voters racine
received return envelopes with the wrong
return address in virginia a thousand
some voters
uh who voted twice that's not including
any of the incompetence
which is to the tune of millions that's
just the active outright
fraud by the way in almost all scenarios
on behalf of the democratic party yeah
3.9 million people requested ballots in
08 did not receive them
3.9 million
election workers are prohibited
currently by law eight states
from even beginning to process ballots
even take them out of the envelopes and
flatten them until election day that
means that it's likely because there's
going to be a huge increase
in mail-in balloting that we are not
going to know
on election night who the winner is that
it could be days
it could be weeks until we find out who
the
the new president is so i first for you
sir
finally for the for the vice president i
hope neither of you will interrupt the
other
will you urge your supporters to stay
open
during this extended period not to
engage in
any civil unrest and will you pledge
tonight that you will not declare
victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you my supporters
to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen i
am urging them to do it as you know
today there was a big problem in
philadelphia they went in to watch they
were
called poll watchers a very safe very
nice thing they were thrown out they
weren't allowed to watch
you know why because bad things happen
in philadelphia bad things
and i am urging i am
but if i see tens of thousands of
ballots being manipulated
i can't go along with that and i'll tell
you what is that from a common sense
does that mean you're going to tell your
other people
it means you have a fraudulent election
you're sending out
these people aren't equipped to handle
it number one number two okay they cheat
they cheat hey they found ballots it's
just a waste paper basket
three days ago and they all had the name
military ballots they were military
they all had the name trump on them vice
president i think that's good
vice president biden final question for
you will you urge your supporters to
stay calm
while the vote is counted and will you
pledge not to declare victory
and if there's thousands of ballots
going to take time to do it and by the
way
our military they've been voting by
ballots
first since at the end of the civil war
in effect and that's
and that's what's happened going to
happen why was it not why is it for them
somehow not fraudulent it's the same
process because they've had a system
that's been placed for
decades because they're also fighting
battles overseas
fraud related to male imbalance that
somehow it's a fraudulent process it's
already been established
this is a perfect moment for everyone
who's going to be for all our blaze
mug club members who are going to be
here afterwards this is the question
i'm most curious to have you talk about
in the chat that we can get to when we
get to that live chat
is which is the question that each
candidate
answered worse that you have heard
having heard the answers heard the
analysis
and i want you to say not just about
trump but also biden as well
do both because there are more debates
to come i'm curious to hear what
as in more debates as we go on uh
president trump he's extended an officer
i hate all of that i want to thank you
both get that all the brand they
overpower the pizza
or it's it's it's all you can taste i
like breadsticks
out of my face stop ruining comedy
cheryl and do whatever
the next love sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
will be one week from tomorrow october
7th at the university of utah
in salt lake city the two vice
presidential nominees vice president
democratic presidential debate it's a
weird
it's a weird system where they have the
democratic presidential candidate debate
the republican vice presidential
candidate i'm not sure how people
it's going to be harris versus pence oh
yeah
so if you want to see the real uh dnc
president the currently uh nominated
president you watch the
vp debates it's a little bit confusing
with the rule book
then again so is mail in voting so so
stephen i'm curious like what your
your hot take right after having seen
you know gone through this debate seen
that first 90 minutes
um say this you're a fantastic lawyer
you have a lot of good qualities but if
you use the phrase hot take again
uh you will be replaced with a jew with
a lot of vowels in his last name
look oh fine
[Laughter]
um i will say this um i i don't know how
well this will play with the
uh american people because donald trump
was being a little
bit what people might expect being a
little bombastic interrupting
but it is remarkable to me that joe
biden has not answered any specifics but
that's the luxury of not having any
accountability as a dnc candidate the
media won't call him on not answering no
with specifics the media wants to make
this a popularity contest
and so you will see them say donald
trump had no uh
no sense of decorum but they won't
really call joe biden to the mat for
being as non-specific as possible
outside of
crazily enough the green new deal that's
kind of the one
thing that tells you who's pulling the
strings in the democratic party it's the
one sort of policy
that no one would fault you for running
away from i mean
it's the thing we talked about earlier
he's got to move somewhere to the middle
to find these folks who want to
do a reasonable plan and yet here he's
talking about a five-page
uh wishing well of ideas that no one can
afford that would destroy the american
economy and yet of all the things that
he chose to memorize it was
that well i mean headlines that's every
single one of his points was a social
justice headline
i think someone told joe biden that
there's no enthusiasm from his base and
so he needs to appeal to the far left
because this is unprecedented in a i i
said at the beginning and i stand
corrected that democrats have had to run
to the center in national debates
this is the contrast this with hillary
clinton contrast this with john kerry
contrast this with al gore
when they were in a general election
they said no no
that's just fear-mongering of course i
don't want to take your guns away of
course i want the average american to
pay less in taxes of course i believe
that businesses
but in this case we had a candidate who
basically read headlines joe biden from
slate from salon from huffington post
an outright defended doubled down on the
green new deal
which is as far left am i out of line
and saying that the green new deal
is as far left of a policy proposal as
has ever been presented in the united
states
other than the weather underground i
mean i mean
it's insane to me that a major party
candidate
would come out and say they're so in
favor when knowing that folks on both
sides of the aisle
know that the green new deal is
unrealistic it hurts working americans
it hurts
every single person talked about nothing
is more non-discriminatory in the way
that it hurts the american economy than
the great new deal
yeah no i think you're absolutely right
and and ironically it hurts uh black
americans more
yeah because again these people don't
understand when he says look we're going
to create more charging stations
think about this for a second joe biden
was saying that if you elect me
you'll have more electric car charging
stations
whereas the leading voice in all of
electric
vehicles elon musk moved
his factory from california to texas
because they wouldn't allow him to
create
cars or charging stations and work
it's one of the there really is a
diametrical opposition a diametric
opposition between
what joe biden thinks and reality and
every single solution proposed by joe
biden involves
hey hey i'll take care of you i'll do
this i'll create more charging stations
i'll make sure that uh you know the
government
ensures safety and security and health
care and
and guarantees that you have access to
whereas whereas donald trump is saying
you know what i'm going to make sure
that you have choices
i'm going to make sure that your bosses
have choices i'm going to put more money
back in your pocket i'm going to make
sure that elon musk has more money in
his company
and the freedom to not be shut down
because of an exaggerated cough
and people will say hold on a second i
don't want this to be fact checked on
youtube
for people under the age of 50. it is a
death rate with covid
very comparable to the flu certainly
more so
than the initially projected mortality
rate of one to
four to seven percent two million
americans dead
uh outside of of course states like new
york and michigan where that is the
death rate because they sent uh young
sick patients into senior living
facilities well
so i gotta say you guys are forgetting
what you're forgetting is that if you're
in poverty in america right now the
number one concern you have is where
your next charging station is going to
be put in
i think that's how yeah that's how out
of touch we
are right yeah when you have no car to
charge
in the first place it's nice to see a
station for the day you do get one
well when your walgreens has been burned
down what are you gonna do with your
model ass
well look i got i gotta i gotta say that
i gotta issue a correction on something
i said earlier because earlier before
the debate gerald said that he thought
that would be better for the president
to go in a certain way and kind of let
joe
biden hang himself on his own speech and
and i was disappointed that the
president
i didn't think that the president did
worse than i expected but i was hopeful
that he would allow joe
to get out there and just hang himself
with zone words and any time joe got
ahead of steam going
it was like wow this guy has no idea
what he's talking about
i will say i was shocked that the more
names called in this entire debate
was by joe joe was the one this clown
over here i'm sorry
uh uh not clown he wasn't even clever
enough to come up with another name like
i'm sorry esteemed colleague he was like
oh this clown over here i'm sorry uh
notes
that donald trump is the only president
who's at times acts non-presidential and
we'll all agree
at times he does act unlike other
presidents but then if you're going to
go ahead and say
well biden he's amazing he always keeps
us cool
he never calls names at anyone we've
seen it on the campaign trail and we saw
it on a debate this was the one moment
that biden had to make sure he stayed on
his game and he couldn't do it and you
were right
along the way it kept getting worse and
worse and worse and worse i want to go
to our closing thoughts here for people
who are mug club members uh thank god
the stream was not shut down tonight
uh final uh word for you guys october
2nd this friday
in lansing michigan at the state capitol
i will be there with some exclusive
information
and a a presentation there first uh the
many of you who are showing up
regarding governor whitmer and the death
toll of seniors and uh how you've been
misled so
this is something again because we've
been told or we've been portrayed as
republicans as conservatives that we
don't care about the most vulnerable
actually governor whitmer it's these
states governor cuomo they don't care
about the most vulnerable among you
they have proactively enacted policies
that resulted in thousands of deaths
verifiably observably and we'll go
through those numbers
and also have some calls to action for
everyone there right now who's seen
enough of this who's seen enough
absurd nursing home policies michigan
october 2nd and lansing
uh do we have the winner of the costume
company we do have the constantine
contest winner it looks like it is
a gentleman named vake uh yeah
there he is wow that's like a strong
that is
absolute insanity the tiny mug it's the
stuff that nightmares are made of
i love it it looks like wish master
stephen can i say something about
michigan i i really got to say something
about why people need to tune in why
they need to have their friends tune in
even if they're
center or center left is because this is
the topic that you've been talking about
you're a michigan native
you've you've known about these numbers
you're bringing this presentation
together
every time anyone tries to bring up the
michigan numbers about the senior deaths
and how they're being covered up and the
data is not being released
we get into a new news cycle and it's
just it's dissipated yeah
you're going to bring it all together on
friday you've been sending requests
and you really care about what's gonna
happen this is something that if you
care about coronavirus numbers
regardless of the size you're on you
need to pay attention to what's
happening on friday and not only that i
have
uh relatives who work as nurses in
michigan and i have a 97 year old
grandmother in michigan
so i have people i have skin in the game
with family members who are
uh direct victims of the policies that
you would see from governor whitmer
and of course she's tried to make she
tried to maintain the optics that hey
look we flatten the hospital curve
well you know how they did that by
stuffing young sick
covid patients into nursing homes
because who would suspect the nursing
home debts because 25
of any deaths in any given week come
from nursing homes there is a reason
that texas florida have a third the
death rate of states like new york and
then if you compare population size
there's a reason that indiana
that these other states neighboring
michigan that states with the same
population density
south carolina tennessee are not even
close to states like michigan
governor whitmer has one leg to stand on
as it relates to her
her her uh her status as it relates to
reelection as it relates to this
trust that the public has given to her
and that is she kept your seniors safe
she kept michiganders safe
i will make a definitive case as to why
that is the
opposite of the truth governor whitmer's
policies she's been saying she wants to
launch an investigation into donald
trump for not doing enough
as it relates to kovid well you know
what first off governor whitmer you
first
and you've done too much it's pretty
tough to measure a non-action right it's
pretty tough to quantify that
it's not tough to say oh wait a second
you vetoed a bill from republicans that
said hey hold on a second let's just not
send young sick patients into nursing
homes let's just not
send people to nursing homes when
there's no quarantining
system in effect let's make sure that if
people are being quarantined before
going into nursing homes that they're in
a separate building
you vetoed that and you put pressure on
nursing homes
on assisted living homes on adult foster
care facilities and homes for the age
to take young sick covert patients
that's what's crazy about michigan
it's insane it's not just old sick
patients who left the nursing and went
to the hospital
and there was policy like you saw in new
york where they said you have to take
these patients back
in michigan they said by the way you're
going to take 21 year old paranoid
schizophrenics into your nursing homes
too
and then we're going to cover up and lie
about the deaths so it's a cause that's
near and dear to my heart it'll be
entertaining and uh
it'll poke a finger in the chest now by
the way it'll it won't poke a thing in
the chest of
governor that would be no it would be
that yeah that would be joe
inappropriate
it'll just be it'll be figured like i'll
be tapping her on the shoulder
avoiding any any any manual or tissue
just to be clear but i think she's gonna
have a rough time so that's friday
october 2nd in michigan we are going to
go now to
light of course mug club for exclusive
unfiltered
final takes not hot takes on these
debates and taking your chat
let's go youtube we love you piss off